I wish they knew that they viewed it as
absolutely barbaric not to have
maternity and paternity leave I wish
they knew that they viewed it as
barbaric not to have health insurance I
mean not just as strange but as barbaric
I wish they knew that they consider all
of these things to be rights and not
privileges or benefits as they kept
called in salary packages I wish they
knew that you know it is infinitely more
pleasurable to live in a place with
great public transportation where you
don't have to jump into a car every
second to you know buy a bottle of milk
it's not simply that it's better for the
environment that the entire quality of
life improves I wish they knew that
Europeans are mystified by the number of
hand gun deaths and by the fact that I
can let my teenage girls go out I mean I
go to sleep before they do in the middle
of Berlin and they go out they go to
clubs they go to art exhibits and enjoy
themselves they come home on safe public
transportation I neither have to worry
about there being hit by a drunk driver
nor being mugged by a you know a poor
person because you can have a
functioning Society if you view all of
those things as rights that are well
worth paying higher taxes for because
they give you an overall quality of life
even if again the salary that you don't
have the salary differential that you do
here you don't have people making giant
you have some people making giant
amounts of money but not nearly as money
but that it is infinitely worse even in
the terms of sheer self-interest it's
worth living in a society where rights
are
also economic and social rights are
distribute in that way because
everybody's life is better
interesting question I think
in general there's one absolutely
there's one piece of consensus across
Europe and in other places where I'm in
contact with opinion makers is that a
third Bush administration would be a
complete and total disaster and people
do see mackade as a nicer version of
bush people feel that America's
leadership role has been almost
completely damaged leadership on all
kinds of issues on foreign policy on the
environment people would like America to
play a leadership role there isn't
anybody else is really stepping up to
the plate although Europe is doing a
great job at its own institutions it
hasn't been able to agree even on the
idea that they should play a leadership
role in foreign policy much less what
that role should be and China and Russia
are not exactly alternatives that
anybody feels like putting their faith
in so people would love for the u.s. to
play a leadership role but they feel
that a third Republican term would be a
disaster as far as that's concerned as
far as the race for Democratic
nomination goes people have been
following it like never before but I
checked my bags in at the airplane the
day after the Pennsylvania election and
I haven't had time to read all the
commentary night was asking the man who
was checking me in if they had
newspapers beyond the barrier if I
should buy a newspaper before him this
is we have newspapers i said i need the
International Herald Tribune because I
have to check the election and he turns
to me says Pennsylvania I'll give you
the numbers if it is it don't worry I
got the numbers first thing in the
morning i need the commentary this is an
ordinary baggage check man who asked me
to explain the super delegate system to
him they're following it with enormous
interest and intensity there's a little
bit of I would say there's a preference
for Senator Obama over senator Clinton
if only because
Europeans are concerned that another
Clinton administration would be to
dynastic they worry about you know
generations of bushes and and Clinton's
taking over from each other and they
feel like that's not democratic they're
not they don't quite understand American
idealism and it's an important
difference I've been on several programs
trying to explain the election to the
German media and they focus on the
rhetoric the injection religion into
politics makes them very nervous and
frankly this is something that I
understand it at a German audience when
they see a screaming crowds yelling yes
we can they get nervous about screaming
proud crowds and politicians and so they
keep asking me well is Obama a demagogue
is he a religious figure and I have to
explain no I think this is a genuinely
grassroots campaign and people just get
excited because it's been such a long
time since people been able to be
positively excited about something